Transcription: eric vautier
Relecteur: Claire Ghyselen
(Musique)
(Fin de la musique)
(Applaudissements)
Delphine Filloux : Merci infiniment
du cadeau que tu nous as fait
pour l’entrée des spectateurs,
il y avait la vidéo du TEDxLaBaule
sur nos magnifiques plages.
Et puis cette vidéo.
Très cher Pierre-Louis,
comment décrirais-tu ton travail ?
En quoi il est différent
de celui d’un dessinateur ?
Pierre-Louis Cullier :
Ce qui est différent,
c’est qu’au lieu de dessiner sur papier,
je dessine sur la plage.
À défaut d’utiliser un crayon,
j’utilise un râteau.
Je suis tributaire de la nature,
des marées,
du soleil, du mauvais temps et de tout ça.
Voilà.
DF : C’est tout ton corps
qui est en mouvement.
En effet, ton travail, c’est la nature
qui décide quand tu peux y aller
et quand elle efface ton travail.
Quand on te regarde travailler,
mais aussi tous ces magnifiques résultats,
c’est très apaisant.
PLC : Effectivement j’ai la chance d’avoir
parfois un public qui vient me voir,
des passants qui passent, qui se baladent.
Ce qui en est ressorti
de tous ces témoignages,
c'est que ça détend.
Je vois ça un peu
comme une danse méditative.
Mais c’est plutôt car je fais
des mouvements sur la plage.
Beaucoup de personnes me disent
que c’est méditatif.
Quand je dessine, c’est vrai
que je me mets dans ma bulle.
J’utilise un casque
pour mettre ma musique,
ça me détend et je suis
dans ma bulle quand je dessine.
DF : Ça te prend combien de temps
pour réaliser un dessin ?
PLC : Ça me prend une à quatre heures.
Ça dépend de la taille du dessin
et surtout du détail que j’y mets.
DF : Très bien.
Et donc, on en est -
Quelle est la genèse de ce projet ?
Finalement, comment ça a débuté ?
PLC : Comme je le disais, j’ai commencé
sur les plages à côté de chez moi.
à Saint-Brévin.
J’ai découvert ça
par jben art, un beach artist -
on appelle cette discipline comme ça.
Jben art est un artiste royannais,
qui dessine sur les plages de Royan.
J’ai découvert ça par Internet.
Je me suis dit que
l’idée de dessiner sur la plage,
en sachant que je dessinais
déjà sur papier,
je me suis dit :
« Tiens, on va l’essayer. »
J’ai attrapé mon râteau et j’y suis allé.
Au début, c’étaient
des mandalas, comme ça.
Puis j’ai commencé
à perfectionner tous ces traits.
Ça m’a amené aux animaux,
puis, ces derniers temps, aux portraits.
DF : Tu as un peu anticipé,
mais ce n’est pas grave.
Tu as eu la chance de rencontrer
la personne réputée dans ce domaine.
Elle t’a dit :
« Sors de ta zone de confort. »
Mais tu as provoqué ta chance aussi.
PLC : Oui, j’ai eu la chance
de le rencontrer.
Il m’a dit d’essayer
de sortir de ma zone de confort
qui était à cette période-là les mandalas.
Chose que j’ai faite.
Le lendemain, je me suis lancé.
Mon premier dessin donc qui sortait
des mandalas, c’était celui-là.
DF : La diapositive des amoureux.
Tu ne voulais pas que je le dise,
mais je le dis.
(Rires)
Tu as provoqué ta chance,
mais aussi quand on a une passion
aussi jeune, à quatorze ans,
on a parfois un environnement familial
qui ne favorise pas toujours
d’exprimer cette passion.
Mais explique-nous ton parcours scolaire.
Qu’est-ce que tu as dû faire ?
Quels ont été tes choix ?
PLC : J’ai eu la chance d’être accompagné,
par mes parents qui sont là.
J’ai pris cette décision de quitter
le cursus scolaire au niveau du lycée.
J’étais au lycée général à La Baule
et j’ai décidé de changer ça pour essayer
de me lancer plus dans ma passion,
et de continuer quand même,
pour faire plaisir aux parents,
un cursus donc à distance
dans le webdesign et l’infographie.
Ça me permet de pouvoir
continuer ce que j’aime faire.
DF : Eh bien bravo ; s’il y a
des tout jeunes dans la salle,
bravo pour cette prise
de risque et cet exemple.
Alors c’est malgré tout -
Pour ton jeune âge, c’est
une activité qui est assez solitaire.
On pourrait se dire que,
parfois, on s’ennuie un peu.
Mais tu as été malin et tu as trouvé
des solutions pour le faire en équipe.
PLC : C’est ça : j’ai réuni quatre
artistes autour d’un même thème,
qui est les chevaux.
Émilie était dans la partie vidéo,
elle a fait toute la vidéo.
Kellyane Richard est une cavalière
qu’on a amenée sur cette vidéo.
Et pour finir Hélène, sans qui
cette vidéo n’aurait pas vu le jour
puisque c’est elle qui a créé le dessin
que j’ai reproduit sur la plage.
On va vous proposer de regarder la vidéo.
DF : Exactement.
(Musique)
[Inspiré des Sabots d’Hélène]
[Arteffetmer]
[Kellyane Richard]
[Réalisation Émilie Beaulieu
Photos Vidéos]
[Inspiration : Hélène Lénaïg]
(Fin de la musique)
(Applaudissements)
PLC : Merci.
DF : Les gens qui te regardent
disent qu’en effet, c’est apaisant.
Tu nous a expliqué que c’était
une vraie danse méthode méditative,
une activité à part entière.
On se pose la question :
« N’est-ce pas frustrant
de voir tout ce travail
effacé par les vagues ? »
PLC : C’est un peu le jeu, de faire
le dessin et qu’ensuite ça s’efface.
Ça ne me dérange pas du tout.
Je prends du plaisir à redessiner
le lendemain, le surlendemain, etc.
J’aime bien comparer la plage
à une feuille blanche
et la mer à une gomme
qui emporte ce dessin.
DF : Tu t’inscris finalement
dans le temps présent.
C’est cette valeur que tu donnes
au temps présent, bien ancré.
Puisqu’il n’y a plus de passé, il n’y a
pas vraiment de futur à ces dessins.
Tu m’avais dit que c’était
des marqueurs dans le temps,
que, parfois,
quand tu revoyais les photos,
tu te disais :
« Là, j’étais dans telle émotion. »
Finalement, il y a quand même une trace.
Ce sont ces émotions que tu ressens
quand tu vas décider de dessiner.
Là, on voit un joli papillon, on a
même l’impression qu’il est en relief.
Ce sont tes toutes dernières créations.
En t’écoutant, tu t’inscris
dans le temps présent,
tu lui donnes une vraie valeur.
Est-ce que c’est plus globalement
ta vision de l’existence ?
PLC : Si je devais retenir une chose
de tout ce que je fais,
c’est que, pour moi, le chemin
compte plus que le résultat.
J’aime en fait dessiner et c’est
surtout ce plaisir que j’y prends.
Le résultat, je prends aussi
du plaisir à le voir,
mais c’est surtout créer le jour,
le lendemain, etc. et recommencer.
J’aime que ce soit
un éternel recommencement.
DF : Un éternel recommencement.
On va vous laisser avec une dernière vidéo
(Applaudissements)
que Pierre-Louis a faite spécialement
pour nous, sur le thème de l’existence.
Quelle surprise !
(Musique)
(Fin de la musique)
(Applaudissements)
Merci.